botagne 5 ans après certains veulent
croire que la mobilisation peut repartir
alors que le prix du carburant reste
élevé Fabien RER et pompéo copola sont
retournés voir des gilets jaunes du côté
de saint-briux on est là on est là on
est là ils sont quelques irréductibles
réunis pour célébrer un anniversaire
c'est des gilet jeunes du 17 novembre
2018 ils sont là depuis le début il ont
jamais lâché depuis 5 an Tristan Irène
Joë et les autres retrouvent leur place
forte le rond-point de brésillet à la
sortie de saint-briilleeux lieu
emblématique du mouvement des gilets
jaunes en Bretagne si on on avait fait
notre QG quoi c'était on avait construit
une cabane on avit construit même un
dortoir pour ceux qui restaient
surveiller le QG des gilets jaunes non
ici c'est beaucoup beaucoup de bons
souvenirs de très bons souvenirs ici on
lâche rien on lâche rien on lâche rien
il y a la joie de se retrouvé mais aussi
de la colère à cause d'une situation
sociale encore plus précaire qu'il y a 5
ans
en
2018 le carburant était 142 143 là on
frôle les 2 € sans arrêt les kilomètres
il rétrécissent pas les voitures
consomment toujours autant mais le
budget essence a été multiplié par de
voire par TR pour certains foyer pouvoir
d'achat prix des carburants les
revendications restent intactes quelques
automobilistes manifestent leur soutien
de quoi donner espoir attristant de voir
le mouvement repartir les revendications
comporté en 2018 on les porte jour
aujourd'hui c'est c'est encore plus cher
maintenant et je pense même que ceux
ceux qui nous soutenaient pas il y a 5
ans se rendent compte aujourd'hui que la
vie est compliquée et que maintenant
peut-être qu'ils nous comprennent aussi
du le pourquoi on a été obligé de se
mobiliser mais tous ne croient pas à une
résurrection des gilets jaunes
fabriceette vit à louéac ce gilet jaune
de la première heure a pris ses
distances avec le mouvement auquel il
reproche de s'être égaré dans des
revendications Fourtout par exemple au
sujet du vaccin pendant le covid le
terro il est fertile ici il y a pas de
souci le pouvoir d'achat l'augmentation
des des loyers même ici on la
ressent l'augmentation des prix du
carburant tout t tous les éléments sont
réunis pour que il y a un mouement un
nouveau moment contestataire
mais il ne peut avoir lieu que si on
s'appuie sur des bases solides c'est
toujours c'est toujours la même chose
revendiquer pour revendiquer et et
derrière ne pas être capable de
d'expliquer réellement sa revendication
on ça va pas nous mener à nouveau bien
loin avec son association Fabrice mise
sur l'éducation populaire et organise
des soirées débats auxquelles il convie
aussi des élus ces mêmes élus locaux qui
en 2018 étaient les premiers
interlocuteurs des gilets jaunes les
gilets jaunes étaient installés ici sur
ce terrain que j'avais mis à disposition
effectivement et il y avait une sorte de
camp de base avec une partie accueil du
public et permanence maire de Plérin
ronand cardraon avait mis ce terrain à
la disposition des gilets jaune pour
qu'ils y installent leur camp de base
s'il ne reste aujourd'hui aucune trace
de leur passage tout n'est pas rentré
dans l'ordre l'élu local se fait du
souci pour l'avenir de son territoire je
suis très inquiet moi pour les années
qui viennent parce que aujourd'hui on
peut considérer que le gouvernement n'a
pas entendu ce mouvement c'est
regrettable la situation on a une partie
de la population qui s'est encore plus
paupérisé théâtre d'une très forte
mobilisation en 2018 la Bretagne sur
l'étincelle qui pourrait faire repartir
la révolte du pouvoir d'achat entre
résignation et amertume Nicolas maer
signignal on l'a entendu dans le
reportage des ces gens dire le Terrero
est encore fertile les revendications
qu'on porte sont les mêmes qu'il y a 5
ans est-ce que ça veut dire que le feu
couv encore oui absolument parce que en
vérité rien n'est résolu moi je suis
maire de rouan qui est une ville
portuaire industrielle la vallée de
seinene c'est un territoire industriel a
il y a trois enjeux il a d'abord la
situation sociale euh les gens
littéralement pour certains crèvent de
faim parce que là on parle de l'essence
mais c'est aussi l'inflation c'est le
prix des des denrées alimentaires de
première nécessité est-ce que la
situation s'est améliorée en 5 ans au
contraire elle s'est aggravée le
deuxième sujet c'est ce que disait Bruno
Latour le sociologue c'estàdire les
gilets jaunes comme des migrants de
l'intérieur la sensation que le pays les
a abandonné il y a plus d'infrastructure
dans les territoires notamment dans la
ruralité je vous donne deux exemples
chez moi pour prendre le train c'est une
galère absolu la Bretagne on vient d'en
parler à pinul demander à la mère de
pinul ni chappé faut un an pour une
mammographie un an pour une mammographie
l'hôpital de pintpul voilà ça c'est des
sujets concrets de service public ou de
service au public puis un troisième
sujet c'est la démocratie le référendum
le RIC l'initiative voilà c'est les
sujets d'entente d'écoute alors là les
maires et les élus locaux peuvent vous
en parler les fermandes sont toujours là
Nicolas en tout cas la la situation pour
les catégories qui se sont engagé dans
le mouvement des gilets jaunes elle a
pas foncièrement changé et puis euxmêmes
ont une perception que rien n'a été fait
pour eux même si c'est pas totalement
euh exact mais le sentiment de de
déclassement vous l'évoqueiez les
difficulté de pouvoir d'achat et puis
cette idée que que les élites ne sont
pas à l'écoute qu'elles sont lointaines
et et qu'elles ne comprendront jamais ça
ça demeure donc ça veut dire que les
éléments les ferments d'un d'un
mouvement social contestataire ceux de
2018 ils sont toujours là après ce que
ça veut dire que il y aura une étincelle
on l'a entendu qui pourrait faire
redémarrer le feu c'est assez improbable
pourquoi parce que beaucoup de personnes
qui était dans ce mouvement aujourd'hui
sont plutôt résignés le sentiment que ça
n'a servit à rien de se mobiliser
pendant autant de semaines et puis un
comportement politique qui est davantage
tourné vers l'abstention que vers la
participation et quand il y a
participation elle va dans une majorité
relative c'est ce que montre les les
sondeurs au rassemblement national donc
est-ce que aujourd'hui un tel mouvement
pourrait redémarrer les ferments
existent est-ce qu'il y aurait une
étincelle c'est difficile d'autant plus
que le gouvernement a un peu tiré les
leçons son de ce qui s'était passé et
essaie d'éviter tout ce qui pourrait
être perçu comme étant une atteinte
directe au pouvoir d'achat ou alors des
mesures qui qui qui qui qui s'en
prendraiit symboliquement à ces
catégories sociales là et c'est pour ça
que on a assisté ces dernières semaines
à des retraits de mesures ou des pistes
qui ont été abandonnées je pense en
particulier aux franchises médicales qui
est qui devait être relevé qui ne le
seront pas ou alors l'histoire des
tickets restaurants qui don don l'usage
sera maintenu ça c'est des types de
mesures qui sont directement lié à ce
qu' vécu
l'exécutif g Jaun exactement et qui sont
dans qu'on peut analyser comme étant des
suites des gilets jaunes comment
l'expliquer cette usure le fait que que
toutes ces personnes soi soi résignées
mais parce que elles ont le sentiment
pour beaucoup de pas avoir obtenu quoi
que ce soit alors qu'elles se sont
mobilisé pendant très longtemps alors
que le mouvement était extrêmement
médiatisé et et elles se disent mais ça
n'a servi à rien je je je je n'ai pas vu
mon quotidien changer alors que nous
étions nombreux alors qu'on passait à la
l euh et ça ça nourrit une résignation
profonde une désinffection du politique
qui est encore plus forte que auparavant
euh même si la réalité est quand même un
peu différente parce que il faut se
souvenir tout de même que le
gouvernement a très rapidement renoncé à
la mesure qui était là l'étincelle du
moment à savoir l'augmentation des taxes
sur l'essence ça ça a été abandonné très
très vite et malgré cet abandon et
malgré les baisses d'impôts qui ont été
décidés après on compte quand même une
dans l'ensemble une dizaine de milliards
de mesures malgré cela le mouvement
c'est pour suivi alors après il y a
d'autres raisons on pe on peut en parler
pendant longtemps mais la perception des
gens sur les rond-points c'est que on n
pas fait grand chose pour eux ouais
Nicolas Maignon Nicolas Prissette le
rappel il y a eu des mesures portées par
le gouvernement après cette crise des
gilets jaunes pour vous il n'a rien
entendu le gouvernement non j'essaie
d'être d'être nuancé mais est-ce qu'on
peut honnêtement dire queil y a plus de
colère et que tout va mieux pas pas du
tout et c'est pas parce que la colère ne
s'exprime pas ou plus c'est pas très
marrant hein d'être tous les toutes les
semaines sur un rond-point où il fait
froid où il pleut bon c'est pas parce
qu'elle ne s'exprime plus qu'elle
n'existe plus c'est c'est c'est ça je
crois qu'il faut dire et puis les vraies
mesures qu'il faudrait d'abord faudrait
de la transparence parce que les cahiers
de doléance comme on a dit à l'époque
ils sont où vous les avez- vousous moi
je pas bah les élus locaux les citoyens
les gilets jaunes tout le monde en fait
aimerait bien les avoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'on les publie pas donc de la
transparence de du courage faut dire les
choses le péril écologique il est
toujours là est-ce que l'essence va
diminuer dans les 30 dans les 50 ans qui
viennent franchement non on doit changer
de modèle donc il faut aussi du courage
politique mais le courage politique il
s'accompagne de mesures concrètes les
salaires les salaires la question du
pouvoir d'achat les retraites les
retraites là on en a pas parlé dans le
reportage notamment pour les femmes 40 %
en moyenne de retraite en moins pour les
femmes on a vu que dans les gilets
jaunes moi chez moi à Rand dans les
gilets jaunes vous aviez des hommes vous
aviez aussi des femmes des petites
mamies comme on dit qui disent moi j'ai
jamais manifesté de ma vie mais ce que
je constate c'est que il faut que je
brûle une poubelle que je sois sur un
rond-point pour qu'on m'écoute ça c'est
pas normal et derrière il y a un enjon
démocratique vous avez dit quelque chose
de très important abstention et vote
extrême droite c'est ça qui se profile
et pas qu'en France est-ce qu'on
continue comme ça ou est-ce qu'on essaie
aussi de défendre notre démocratie et
notre République parce que c'est aussi
ça l'enjeu qui est derrière qu'est-ce
qu'on fait quelle est pour vous la
solution d'abord on dit la vérité sur
les changements qu'il faut opérer dans
notre société ensuite on prend ce ne
fait pas Emmanuel Macron non je pense
pas sur la question environnementale je
pense qu'il n'est pas suffisamment
courageux je dis pas qu'il fait rien je
pense qu'il faut dire les choses sur les
la profondeur et l'intensité des
transformations que l'on doit faire
quand on dit par exemple sur
l'artificialisation des sols aux élus
locaux non mais vous allez voir ça va
bien se passer excusez-moi mais c'est à
peu près ça alors qu'on sait très bien
que c'est extrêmement difficile et que
ça a des conséquences concrèes y compris
pour les gilets jaunes y compris pour
des gens qui habitent loin et qui tout
d'un coup voit leur maison perdre en
valeur alors là on manque de courage et
de vision ensuite il faut des
propositions concrètes d'abord les
salaires d'abord les salaires la
question des retraites la question du
pouvoir d'achat et là il y a des choses
à faire moi je veux pas comment dire
opposer les uns et les uns aux autres
mais quand vous voyez que les plus hauts
salaires des plus haut dirigeants sur 10
ans ont augmenté de 60 % quand les
salaires en France en moyenne ont
augmenté de 30 % sur la même période ça
veut dire qu'il y a un problème moi je
suis pas pour opposer mais quand même il
y a un sujet de salaire et notamment
pour les plus modestes et pour les
classes moyennes et puis et puis les
services publics j'ai parlé de la santé
tout à l'heure les trains enfin des
choses concrètes pour le quotidien des
gens et pour ça il faut s'appuyer sur
quoi mais sur les élus locaux sur les
collectivités local parce que c'est eux
qui sont apportés d'engueulade ce qu'il
a fait Emmanuel Macron pendant cette
crise des gilets jaunes il a lancé les
grands avec des maires les maires ont
beaucoup aidé Emmanuel Macron pendant
cette période est-ce que aujourd'hui
vous il le referait bah vous dites les
maires vous avez raison les maires ont
beaucoup aidé Emmanuel Macron ou le
gouvernement et moi j'essaie de le dire
en responsabilité ça serait bien que le
gouvernement et Emmanuel Macron aide
beaucoup les maires ce qu' fait pas on
va y venir puisque on va parler de ce
qui s'est passé hier soir à l'ésée mais
sur les mesures dont as parlé Nicolas
mayorossignol Nicolas Priss est-ce que
le gouvernement il peut entendre ça il
essaye c'est-à-dire que le le la
difficulté euh de de de de quand vous
devez répondre à une attente qui est
celle de de de ces classes moyennes ces
petites classes moyennes la difficulté
c'est les leviers sont pas immédiat je
m'explique le levier fiscal aujourd'hui
on pourrait parler de d'une baisse
d'impôt sur le revenu qui est le type de
mesure assez classique qu'un
gouvernement prend on l'a vu depuis 30
ans quand il faut répondre à une demande
sociale sauf que là on a des catégories
sociales qui ne payent pas d'impôt sur
le revenu ou très peu donc les mesures
qui pourraient s'adresser à à elle à
travers ce ce levier là elles sont pas
très efficaces et sinon elles sont
extrêmement coûteuses parce que s'il
faut réinstaller des services publics à
un niveau auquel ils sont attendus ou
espéré par la population à ce moment-là
on va remettre des hôpitaux dans toutes
les petites villes et et il y a personne
pour les financer donc le la cette
difficulté de d'arriver à avoir un bon
niveau de service public qui soit
satisfaisant tout en étant pas onéreux
là là il y a vraiment un un écueil
politique qui sur lequel seent tous les
gouvernements pas uniquement celui
d'aujourd'hui arriver à remettre du lien
social par des moyens c'est extrêmement
compliqué c'est pour ça que il y a cette
demande qui est faite de façon
permanente au maire de leur demander de
que ce soit eux qui financent l'ensemble
des des réhabilitations ou des
restaurations de services publics dans
les territoires Nicolas signal vous
parliez des questions démocratiques
notamment de la question du référendum
Emmanuel Macron il veut élargir le champ
du référendum il veut faciliter pardon
le référendum d'initiative populaire en
abaissant les seuils partager en
abaissant les
seuils non c'est le rip bon ça facilite
quand même le référendum il veut baisser
le nombre de parlementaires il veut
baisser le nombre de signatures est-ce
que ça va dans le bon sens c'est une
mesure c'est c'est c'est pas négligeable
et on peut évidemment en discuter je
voulais juste être précis parce que vous
avez le référendum c'est un peu
compliqué à expliquer mais d'initiative
partagée et le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne la demande des gilets jaunes
éta c'est sur le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne là-dessus il y a pas d'avancé
on parle de ce que vous venez de dire
concerne le référendum d'initiative
partagée à baisser le seuil c'est sans
doute utile puisque jusqu'à présent en
fait en pratique il n'a jamais pu être
utilisé donc c'est bien que le seuil est
probablement trop haut aujourd'hui mais
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
restaurer le lien de confiance
démocratique moi je crois pas du tout je
pense qu'en fait le principe qui doit
nous guider c'est d'essayer de faire en
sorte que les la boucle démocratique
c'est-à-dire le lien entre les citoy et
leurs représentants soit la plus courte
possible et la plus proche du quotidien
des Françaises et des Français je vous
donne un exemple concret très simple
parce que là on parle des gilets jaunes
on pourrait parler des émeutes de
juillet dernier dans les quartiers
populaires c'est pas le même sujet mais
il y a quand même une violence et une
force et là encore rien n'est résolu
aujourd'hui bon aujourd'hui quand vous
voulez abattre une tour un vieux HLM des
années 70 quand vous voulez avancer dans
un quartier vous savez comment ça se
passe pour les élus locaux vous devez
aller passer un grand taoral à Paris
devant une agence nationale qui est très
bien pleine de gens compétents vous
attendez des années vous revenez dans
votre quartier et vous dites aux jeunes
du quartier qui ont plus leur centre
social qui voient des immeubles avec des
logements véus depuis des années
toujours en place avec du squat avec des
incendies et vous leur dites attendez
encore 5 ans et dans 5 ans on aura
peut-être les crédits comment vous
voulez que ça ce soit entendable les
gars il vous disent mais attendez
Monsieur le Maire mais nous dans 5 ans
on est plus jeune et on est plus dans le
quartier ou alors si on y encore on
pourrait avoir des problèmes et vous
aussi voilà c'est ça la réalité de
terrain donc faites confiance au local
pas pour tous les sujets il y a des
sujets nationaux la justice bien entendu
l'éducation nationale bien entendu mais
il y a des sujets sur lesquels on n pas
besoin d'une aème loi on a besoin de bon
sens de pragmatisme et de travail
ensemble et de confiance moi j'aurais
aimé que par exemple le président de la
République Vienne devant la MF dans
l'association des MRES de France c'est
pas le cas bon je dis pas que rien n'est
fait je dis qu'on peut faire plus et
plus concret vous demandez quoi un choc
de simplification j'ai parlé de
confiance de confiance et de de
pragmatisme je vous ai donné un exemple
très concret sur la rénovation urbaine
moi concrètement je suis en train de
faire mon budget pour ran je dois
avancer l'argent c'est plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros pour
transformer des immeubles amiantés des
bars des tours d'immeubles dans des
quartiers qui sont les quartiers les
plus en difficulté socialement c'est pas
normal autre exemple sur la loi
immigration dont on parle le sujet dont
je vais parler on en parle jamais on se
concentre toujours sur la question la
fermeté versus le laxisme et cetera
qu'est-ce qu'ils vous disent les gens
sur le terrain ils vous disent nous on
n'est pas raciste mais pourquoi est-ce
que les personnes qui arrive sur notre
territoire vous vous avez tendance à les
mettre dans des quartiers où il y a déjà
des difficultés sociales il y a combien
de personnes immigrantes migrantes qui
arrivent à Neil dans les quartiers les
plus chics et c'est vrai la vérité c'est
qu'on les retrouve plutôt dans des
quartiers qui ont déjà des difficultés
sociales donc les lois sur la mixité
sociale sur le logement vous avez pas
besoin d'une nè loi mais mettez-les
vraiment en U parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez des communes qui encore aujourd'hui
préfèrent payer des amendes plutôt que
d'avoir des logements sociaux et de la
vraie mixité voyez travailleer sur
l'éducation quand vous avez des classes
où vous devriez avoir moins de 24 élèves
en maternelle en primaire et vous en
avez déjà 27 28 et que les profs sont
déjà au turbain et VO arriver en plus
des personnes des jeunes enfants qui
n'ont rien fait à personne qui souvent
ont eu des parcours extrêmement difficil
venu d'Afrique de Syrie d'Afghanistan
mais qui parlent pas français qui par
définition n'ont pas notre culture au
départ et que vouz retrouver dans cette
classe vous croyez que c'est plus facile
pour le prof vous croyez que c'est plus
facile pour le quartier c'est ça la
réalité de terrain et tous les élus
locaux connaissent ça et il y a des
solutions concrètes à mettre en œuvre
faut faire confiance Nicolas vous avez
soulevé le point de de de cette relation
de confiance entre les citoyens et les
élus est-ce que les citoyens doivent pas
les élus pardon doivent pas en faire un
tout petit peu plus quand même je prends
juste un point
euh dans le le caractère participatif de
la démocratie si il y a au niveau local
des budgets participatifs il y en a pas
dans toutes les villes mais il y en a de
plus en plus or quand on regarde ça de
près donc on a vraiment là quelque chose
de concret hein c'est c'est ce
qu'attendent les gens participer
davantage mais que leur proposent les
élus qui mettent en œuvre ces budget
participatif c'est s'exprimer sur en
moyenne c'est une moyenne 5 % seulement
des investissements et après ils
viennent regretter qu'il y a pas
davantage de de leurs habitants qui se
rendent à la mairie pour voter le budget
participatif est-ce qu'il y a pas aussi
de la part des élus locaux et pas
uniquement nationaux une nécessité
d'aller un tout petit peu plus loin dans
la promesse démocratique si bien sûrf je
peux partager ce point à rouan et dans
plein de villes il y a des budgets
participatifs vous l'avez dit il y a des
villes qui sont très en point de Laus je
pense à Nantes par exemple avec Johanna
Rolland Renn avec Nathalie apéré bien
sûr on peut toujours faire plus
là-dessus j'introduiraai quand même
peut-être dans le débat une petite
nuance parce que la démocratie
participative ne se résume pas au budget
participatif mais et c'est un des rares
leviers qui existent non je pense que
c'est c'est plus profond que ça dans
participatif vous avez aussi les
conventions citoyennes ce qu'on fait
maintenant dans les communes
c'est-à-dire avec du tirage au sort et
avec des citoyens dont on va réellement
prendre en compte la vie et les
propositions et plein de communes on a
fait ça Grenoble fait ça Paris voilà là
il y a des choses qui sont intéressantes
et puis le budget participatif dont vous
vous parler c'est celui qui va être
décidé directement par les citoyens mais
attendez on peut nous on le fait tous
les jours on peut faire voter nos
citoyens sur l'ensemble du budget sur
d'autres propositions sur l'aménagement
dans tel quartier sur le choix de de de
tel mode de transport donc en fait on
peut aller beaucoup beaucoup plus loin
dans la participation donc bien sûr que
les élus locaux peuvent faire beaucoup
plus mais vous savez franchement les
élus locaux c'est ceux qui sont au
quotidien àortter de BAFF c'est quand
même eux qui sont au front on va en
parler justement des élus locaux puisque
se tient cette semaine le Congrès des
Maires Emmanuel Macron recevait un
millier d'entre eux hier soir à l'Élysée
objectif montré qu'il était à leur
écoute et conscient de leur diff
difficulté on voit ça avec Jonathan
duprz et Cécile
Siou à l'Élysée Emmanuel Macron s'est
adonné à une séance de calinothérapie
auprès des maires de France près d'un
millier d'édil que le chef de l'État a
tenté de rassurer à l'heure où nombre
d'entre eux sont pris pour cible et
tenté de raccrocher face aux difficultés
longtemps décrit comme déconnectés des
élus de terrain Emmanuel Macron a voulu
leur témoigner son soutien vous qui êtes
maire au plus près du terrain vous avez
des compatriotes qui pensent que vous
êtes responsablebles de tout c'est notre
communauté de destin moi c'est pareil et
après quand on commence à leur dire oui
je voudrais bien mais je peux point
parce que ça c'est fait là ça c'est ici
là c'est comm à dire d'accord vous
essayez de
m'embrouiller on voudrait bien
désembrouiller les choses c'est ce qu'on
doit faire à la sortie la tonalité est
plutôt en joué des maires pour la
plupart honoré d'avoir été pris en
considération par le Président de la
République être invité à
l'Élysée c'est nous reconnaître dans nos
fonctions d'él
donc je trouve que c'est important et
puis voilà l'Élysée c'est aussi notre
République française et nous sommes des
élus de la République et ces valeurs là
il faut qu'elles continuent à être au
cœur de nos actions politiques sur le
fond Emmanuel Macron a exploré des
pistes pour améliorer le statut de l'élu
refondre la fiscalité locale ou encore
accélérer la
décentralisation décentralisation qui
fait partie des sujets les plus attendus
pour moi une bonne décentralisation
c'est une décentralisation qui permet on
va dire de rendre des comp à nos
habitants d'une part et puis deux ben de
pouvoir disposer euh bah des moyens
nécessaires pour faire les projets sur
lequel on s'est engagé quand on a mené
notre campagne électorale par exemple
autre sujet sur lequel les maires ont pu
échanger avec le chef de l'État la
sécurité selon laamf les violences
envers les élus ont augmenté de 15 %
cette année j'en ai fait l'objet à titre
physique moral et cetera ça suffit les
élus sont là pour faire de leur mieux on
les aime on les aime pas il y a le juge
de paix c'est l'élection on n'est pas là
pour se faire insulter et on n'est pas
là pour se faire frapper et ça faut que
ça soit compris c'est ce qui fait la
noblesse d'une démocratie de l'aveu
d'une majorité de Mair Emmanuel Macron
semble avoir posé les vrais sujets du
moment mais les élus ne sont pas dupes
et attendent des actes comme l'a rappelé
l'association des m de France dans un
communiqué il a posé les vrais sujets
Emmanuel Macron hier soir Nicolas ma
signal il y a pas d'amour il y a que des
preuves d'amour voilà des réceptions à
l'Élysée des remises de médailles c'est
vrai c'est important c'est c'est
symbolique mais les symboles ça compte
dans notre République et pour ma part je
pense que quand on est invité par le
Président de la République si vous voyez
ce que je veux dire il faut toujours s'y
rendre c'est un message à c'est je
taille large mais parce qu'on est en
République et il faut être respectueux
des institutions ça marche aussi pour
Olivier for dir est-ce que pour autant
c'est suffisant je crois pas on n'est
pas au début du premier mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron on est en fin 2023 il
a été élu en 2017 ou les années comptent
et quand on revient de l'Élysée pour les
maires quel que soit leur sensibilité
politique on retourne au marché du coin
où les gens vous disent alors alors le
train demain il y en a plus ou il y en a
moins il est plus cher ou il est moins
cher la barre d'immeuble dont je vous
parle les jeunes du quartier moi ils me
disent alors c'est ça y est on va la
construire la piscine parce que dans mon
quartier les gamins ils apprennent même
pas à nager où on va continuer à nous
dire que désolé mais ça c'est pas
éligible au financement c'est ça
concrètement donc si vous voulez on peut
faire des réceptions c'est important
c'est symbolique il y a aussi la
question de la protection c'est vrai
mais il faut des actes les actes c'est
pas forcément que de l'argent d'ailleurs
encore une fois j'ai parlé beaucoup de
confiance de réglementation de
simplification au sens pragmatique du
terme pas de libéralisation mais la
confiance ça passe aussi par encore une
fois des circuits démocratiques courts
des circuit court mais là c'est ce qu'il
a dit le chef de l'État Nicolas Priss
est-ce que quand même il fait une erreur
de pas se rendre devant le le Congrès
des Maires et de pas assister à leur
clôure de leur congrès est-ce que je
peux vous interrompre sur ce point
symboliquement c'est intéressant il ne
va pas à la MF il convoque à l'Élysée je
je trouve que là-dessus il y a de
l'ordre d'un d'un symbole qui donne à
voir la conception de la façon dont on
veut travailler ensemble si vous voulez
être plus proche du terrain allez voir
les
maires la situation est la même chaque
année c'est est-ce qu'il va qui risque
de se faire siffler comme la première
fois où il s'est rendu ou bien est-ce
qu'il va pas et on va ce à lui reprocher
d'être haain et et lointain sans doute
il retournera-t-il il reste encore
jusqu'à 2027 pour pour le faire mais la
difficulté politique pour lui c'est de
d'avoir quelque chose à délivrer et des
messages positifs à envoyer aux élus
locaux il en a pas beaucoup en réalité
c'est beaucoup de de promesses promesses
d'aller un peu plus loin dans la
décentralisation c'est le travail qui a
été confié à Eric vert il a évoqué hier
soir un nouveau calcul ou une mise à
jour de la dotation générale de
fonctionnement qui est la principale
subvention en tout cas financement que
verse l'État au aux collectivités
trouver des des recettes qui seraient
plus dynamiques et ça c'est un point
majeur pour les élus locaux puisque les
mairres ont perdu quasiment tout ce
qu'il pouvaient faire en matière de de
de financement le levier fiscal ils ne
l'ont plus avec la suppression la taxe
d'habitation il aura juste une part des
des taxes foncières donc ça veut dire
que quelque part euh il son trouve dans
une situation qui est entre l'élu local
et le haut fonctionnaire dans le dans
leur situation et c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose qui
est une réelle difficulté parce qu'à
partir du moment où vous êtes devant les
concitoyens vous devez leur annoncer un
programme et dire voilà on va rénover la
ville on va avoir une municipalité plus
jolie et puis vous avez pas les moyens
de le faire bah ça crée des difficultés
politiques considérables au niveau local
donc Emmanuel Macron il est bien
conscient de tout ça mais il a pas hier
il pas de de de de solutions magique à
leur proposer non mais personne ne
demande de solutions magique mais encore
une fois j'essaie de donner des des
éléments très concrets je donne un
exemple concret pour rebondir sur ce que
vous venez de dire sur la fiscalité en
faisant le lien avec les transports
rouan comme beaucoup d'autres
territoires sont touchés par ce qu'on
appelle la ZFE la zone à faible émission
pour des raisons de santé écologique on
exclut progressivement mais c'est la loi
c'est même une directive européenne des
véhicules anciens dit polluant bon mais
concrètement socialement ça veut dire
quoi qui a ses véhicules évidemment on
parlait des gilets jaunes tout à l'heure
des gens qui habitent plus loin avec des
véhicules plus anciens avec des revenus
plus modestes avec des difficultés
sociales donc c'est terrible parce que
c'est fin du monde et fin du mois qui se
percutent bon comment vous pouvez
résoudre ça socialement c'est difficile
faut lutter contre la voiture
autosoliste donc faut des alternatives
mais tout le monde peut pas venir au
boulot en vélo donc il faut plus de
train faut plus de transport en commun
et cetera simplement ça coûte faut des
chauffeurs faut des bus faut plus
d'infrastructure ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent investissement et
fonctionnement aujourd'hui pour les les
collectivités locales les transports
c'est financ par ce qu'on appelle le
versement mobilité c'est une fiscalité
qui est aujourd'hui plafonnée et Bercy
et le gouvernement et donc Emmanuel
Macron refuse aujourd'hui de déplafonner
il y a une exception c'est
l'île-de-fance vous connaissez la la
polémique le débat là-dessus très bien
pour l'île-de-fance mais moi je vous dis
dans les secteurs comme chez moi mais il
y en a plein d'autres où la qualité de
l'air est mauvaise où c'est les gens qui
ont déjà les plus grandes difficultés à
qui on doit dire maintenant vous devez
changer de voiture et changer une
voiture ça coûte beaucoup d'argent même
quand on a une voiture d' et même quand
on a une prime et on en met des primes
si en plus on n pas la fiscalité pour
mettre en place plus de transports en
commun on fait comment donc ou ça c'est
un levier concret hein quand on a eu la
pandémie on nous a dit quoi qu'il en
coûte et on en a trouvé de l'argent et
pour de bonnes raisons pour des raisons
sanitaires sur la santé environnementale
sur le transport en commun vous croyez
pas que c'est c'est pas une bonne raison
pour modifier la fiscalité donc dire que
le Président de la République n'a pas de
marge de manœuvre moi je suis pas
d'accord je dis pas qu'il peut tout
faire je dis pas qu'il y a de baguette
magique il y a pas d'argent magique mais
il y a des choix il y a des priorités
politiques il me semble que par exemple
les transports en commun les services
publics de proximité la santé
l'éducation ça ça devrait être des
priorités un dernier mot sur ce que vous
nous avez dit tout à l'heure Nicolas
maorignol on sort un peu du Congrès des
m Olivier fort Tor de pass se rendre
rencontre de saint-is pour vous oui bien
sûr oui bien sûr quand on est un parti
de responsabilité quand on a vocation à
exercer le pouvoir je sais bien que
l'expression gauche de gouvernement
aujourd'hui elle est méprisée elle est
vilipandée enfin si on est démocrate et
si on veut changer la vie des gens ça VE
dire qu'on souhaite gagner des élections
pour exercer le pouvoir donc c'est bien
une gauche de gouvernement appelez ca
comme vous voulez mais enfin moi c'est
ce que je veux faire faire des grands
discours faire des hologrammes et faire
des effets de tribune c'est sympathique
mais ça change la vie de combien de
chômeurs donc il fait du Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour vous j'ai pas dit ça je
dis juste que notre objectif c'est quand
même d'exercer le pouvoir et donc quand
on est dans une situation aussi grave y
compris sur le plan international j'ai
pas besoin de détailler la
responsabilité des partis de
responsabilité bah c'est d'être au
rendez-vous ce qui n'empêche pas les
désaccord
ce qui n'empêche pas de marquer des
oppositions et de faire des propositions
mais je pense que bon voilà les absents
on toujours
tort